narwhals are easily recognized by their
long tusks
but this isolated species of tooth to
whale has been hard to research we know
a little about them but their physiology
and metabolism are still a puzzle to
marine biologists using a specially
engineered device that resembles an
undersea fitness tracker researchers
received some seemingly paradoxical data
in wild Narwhal vital science in most
mammals the flight response they undergo
in reaction to danger causes the heart
rates to increase in order to help blood
flow to the muscles and supply the
oxygen needed during a speedy retreat
for land mammals oxygen is plentiful in
the environment but because aquatic
mammals can't breathe water they have to
hold their breath to help conserve this
stored oxygen they also lower their
heart rate this decrease when diving is
not unusual
narwhals usually bottomed out around 10
beats per minute but the researchers saw
that as they swam away their heart rate
went much lower to under 4 beats per
minutes the problem is that in these
flight situations
narwhals get the conflicting signal to
both dive quickly and beat their hearts
slowly as a result their oxygen supply
gets used up very fast sharply
decreasing the amount of time they can
dive and lab animals subjected to the
same paradoxical physiology sudden death
can occur researchers aren't sure how
these extended periods of hypoxia affect
the narwhals health and with the
increased incursion into their
environment by humans these periods may
become more frequent
for now biologists will have to figure
out how narwhal bodies deal with this
type of stress and if anything can be
done to prevent more of it
[Music]
you